what you been up to these days I've been  busy I've been really busy reading a lot  of Andy's tweets I'm really excited  he's been tweeting a lot about some  important stuff yesterday he had a great  one this is a real one right is it a  real tweet he had a great tweet  yesterday I don't know if we have we  have it yeah we have it go there we go  just ran over a fallen orange in the  alley Karl windows open so receive the  Roma bonus very satisfying ten out of  ten I mean it's called fan out we want  to try it get a code hubris I better  alert the whole world hmm I just tried  something it's called ketchup what are  you talking about I like to share yeah  it's pretty infuriating when he does  isn't it it is  [Laughter]  you